a grim reminder of a tragic day
these grain silos withstood the impact
of a massive chemical explosion at
beirut port in 2020
now nearly two years later they've come
crashing down
a fire hastened the collapse grain
fermenting in the hot weather caught a
light they didn't try to extinguish the
fire and today you can see that the
silos are like collapsing
gasan hazruti was one of more than 200
people who died in the 2020 disaster
his daughter says the silos should never
have been allowed to fall
all this
ruling state is doing to
remove and to demolish our collective
memory this is the only
this is the only thing that has been
has been there since the explosion and
now they're trying to remove it
the explosion was an accident waiting to
happen
thousands of tons of ammonium nitrate
had been sitting in a warehouse for
years
investigations have revealed senior
government and security officials knew
about the dangerous materials stored at
the port
but the inquiry into who should be held
responsible has stalled
so far no one major has faced any
consequences i blame
all the world leaders that now are
wearing suits in the parliament i blame
everybody who's not going to invest to
the investigation and everybody's not
executing the arrest warrants to
continue the investigation i blame
everybody who knew about the ammonium
nitrate and didn't do anything about it
we need to know the truth we need to
know who did this to us and hold them
accountable once we hold
someone accountable for this crime
nothing else will happen again
it seems likely these grain silos won't
be the last to fall
the lebanese government is warning more
could collapse in the coming days and
weeks
further reminders of the devastation of
2020
and of justice and accountability that
continues to be denied
vincent monaghan al jazeera